wenn ihr material von hackern habt egal
welcher art spielmodus mit bett wars
complete survival game center games
skyeurope whatever
dann schickt mir als youtube and
services kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge heute spielen wir
minecraft sowie games auf galladé sp 4
heißt die map world spielen und reisen
schwerter jackpot sehr schön so kann man
noch anfangen leute ich will euch etwas
erzählen und zwar möchte ich euch heute
in diesem video erklären wie ihr es
schaffen könnt in einem video von mir
aufzutauchen in welcher form das sein
wird das erkläre ich euch nachher noch
aber ihr habt auf jeden fall unter
gewissen bedingungen eine gute chance
und eine gute möglichkeit dabei zu sein
in einem video von mir da mal für eine
gewisse zeit im mittelpunkt zu stehen
erwähnt zu werden pipapo alles drum und
dran was so schön hätte es sich um etwa
die alten schätzchen sehr geil etwa 3
hitzel das geht schnell die angel
wunderbar sagt bohm und zwar hatte ich
eine idee für ein neues format und das
format bezieht euch mit allen euch
zuschauer dem habt ihr nämlich die
möglichkeit was von euch zu zeigen
sowas ist erklärt gleich nämlich ich
glaub ich sag noch nicht worum es in
diesem format geht ihr könnt sie
vielleicht denken wir dann die folge zu
ende schaute mir genau zuhört aber auf
jeden fall kann ich da eure hilfe
gebrauchen
und das was ihr quasi erlebt habt werdet
ihr minecraft gespielt hat darum jetzt
ganz konkret und ich sage es jetzt
einfach mal wenn ihr als kleine
vorinformation wenn ihr material hat
also aufgenommen habt wie ihr irgendwie
in einem hacker begegnet seid sei es
dass diese person euch getötet hat
irgendjemand anderen getötet hat ihr
habt's gefilmt oder sonst irgendwelche
seltsame sachen gemacht gemacht hat egal
in welchem spiel modus sei es jetzt im
bett wars irgendwie so ein hacker der
nicht runterfällt oder low power oder
sei es in zwei games einer mit forst
keine ahnung schickt mir das als youtube
tm mit einer erlaubnis dass ich das
video material verwenden darf und wenn
ich die einen sehen cool finde dann habt
ihr die gelegenheit in einem neuen
format von mir aufzutauchen
das demnächst kommen wird das wichtigste
ist halt dass ihr mir in dieser youtube
nachricht die erlaubnis gibt dass sie
ihr material verwenden darf hier leidet
ist dann einfach auch nicht gelistet
hoch würde ich sagen genau das einfach
nicht getestet hoch dann schicken wir
das in youtube en sagte joas hier
einsendungen zum thema das ja letztens
in dem video gesagt sie sollen material
entsenden von hackern die wir gefilmt
haben dann schickte mir das zu und ich
schaue mir alle einsendungen an
und da könnte mir wirklich alles zu
schicken also alles was sie irgendwann
material rumliegen habt ihr können auch
mal eure freunde fragen und garantiert
ist wenn wir das material zu sagt wenn
das coolen witzig ist und ich verwende
werde dir garantiert erwähnt dann wird
euer name in dem video eingeblendet
werden und zwar für die dauer dieses
ausschnitt das werdet ihr zu sehen sein
in dem video + ich werde euch auch
bestimmt noch mal namentlich erwähnen
das heißt ihr könnt dann einfach mal
quasi durch eine einsendung wenn die
coole so einen kleinen gastauftritt
haben
wie das dann am ende doch genau aussieht
seht ihr dann bei der ersten folge aber
jetzt erstmal die bitte an euch wenn ihr
da irgendwas habt in der richtung oder
leute kennt irgendwas haben ich habe
dazu schon mal auf twitter gefragt wenn
man die leute so jo klar haben wir hier
und da davon gibt einmal einiges dann
gerne zu schicken würde mich riesig
freuen über den großen gefallen und
gewissermaßen auch euch selbst denn am
ende wird was richtig richtig cooles
dabei herumkommen
da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher als 10
mio usd
jetzt sind die blätter einer na ja genau
so haben wir vielleicht viele nein keine
pfeile alt habe ich viele leute da sind
geplant schönherr mehr anziehen haben
gut eisen schwert regelt halten ist aber
so
sehr schön haben auch dort und da kommt
der nächste o2 weglaufen
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack ich
glaube dass jeder mensch oder jeder
minecraft spieler irgendwo schon mal im
hacker begegnet ist und das ist auch
sehr viele aufnahmen gibt wenn er zum
beispiel bei irgendeinem server team
arbeitet oder sogar modsite und das von
eurem server aus erlaubt ist könnt ihr
mir auch das material was euch als mod
zu gesendet wurde zu schicken aber wie
gesagt nur wenn es von eurem server
seite aus erlaubt ist dann können wir
auch euch dann also auch mods namentlich
erwähnen aber ruft das lieber zwei mal
so nicht sie am ende wie material habe
und da leute gezeigt werden die nicht
gezeigt werden sollen aber ich glaube da
können wir es richtig gutes draus machen
mir schwebt da schon was vor so eine
kleinigkeit und die runde läuft soweit
eigentlich ganz gut würde ich mal sagen
eines tolle ist halt wenn man den ersten
christen eisens verzieht ist die runde
eigentlich schon nicht geritzt aber dann
kann schon nicht mehr ganz so viel
schief gehen
ich muss dringend moment klären aber
drin denn dies dem okay der goldstadt
leiste werde ich schon holen
da kann auch ein fahrzeug einsetzen kann
jetzt jeder dauern so nächster gegner in
die richtung alles klar kurz mal aus
mühlen ich habe so viel saft alter
anspacher parat lässt sich mal wieder im
stich danke schön still still still
still still still
ich habe übrigens gedacht ich sag jetzt
in dem video noch nicht noch nicht genau
worum es da gehen soll so einfach keine
ahnung
es ist wahrscheinlich unnötig aber
einfach so aus vorsichtsgründen das netz
nicht den ganzen käse schon spoiler
bevor da draußen ist
aber ich kann mir vorstellen dass es
sehr sehr coole format wird dass es
vielen von euch gefallen wird
deswegen hängt eigentlich alles an euch
ihr könnt sie entscheiden was draus wird
wenn ich das material bekommen kann da
sicher sicher sicher einiges draus
machen
roddick startet schon also sendet
fleißig ein
im zweifelsfall lieber mehr einsenden
als zu wenig einfach euren youtube nicht
gelistet hochladen oder notfalls falls
ihr keine account habt vielleicht auch
dropbox oder so wo bei youtube schon
besser ist youtube ist besser schickt
einfach den den youtube-link zudem nicht
gelisteten video und ihr seht es dann
später wir machen das bisschen
überraschungs mäßig also quasi ich gebe
euch nicht vorher bescheid sondern
sollte euer materialien verwendet werden
werdet ihr es im video dann selbst sehen
das ist glaube ich auch ganz witzig und
die wir versprochen wir werden auch eine
erwähnung bekommen und so weiter und so
fort und einen käsekuchen lauterbach
dicke boden praktik imboden der brennt
so mein lieber du brennst habe ich
gehört dann hast du hast nämlich ein
schwert das finde ich nicht so gut
ja es war einfach nicht mehr fünf monate
wie trotzdem gesehen so was jetzt mit
colin gehe kann ich in diesem call und
reingehen auf den court und nicht mal
anklicken alles klar
wegen einem ein kraftakt okay gut dann
klicke ich inhaltlich an ist er
gestorben was ist gestorben
das habe ich überhaupt nicht mit da
fragt auf jeden fall leute nochmal der
aufruf ich habe 25.000 mal gesagt jetzt
zum 20.000 ersten mal wenn ihr material
von hackern habt egal welcher spielmodus
matt walsh jump league sowie game center
games skyworth whatever
dann schickt mir als youtube als nicht
gelistet das video den link zum video
mit einer erlaubnis durch das material
benutzen darf und dann werden was gutes
draus machen und ihr könnt in dem video
von mir oft auch ich hoffe dass es das
cool ist für euch falls ja und falls
euch das video gefallen hat dann lassen